understanding how the surface area of a
cylinder is derived is very interesting
look at this cylinder
it has two blue circular ends
one on top and one at the bottom analyze
the figure
as we know the area of a circle we can
easily find the surface area of the top
and the bottom circular ends
but the important question is
how do we find the surface area of this
curved surface
let's zoom out a bit
first let's separate the circular ends
this is the top one and this is the one
at the bottom
to understand the curved surface
we cut it open vertically which will
make it look like this
we just cut the surface vertically
when this is opened up further it will
look like a rectangle
there are a few questions we need to ask
ourselves here
first what is the length of the
rectangle
and second what is its breath
if you look carefully you will notice
that the length of this rectangle is
actually the circumference of the
circular base
because all we did was pull this open
what about its breadth
its breadth is the height of the
cylinder
let's assume the height of the cylinder
is h
and the radius of the circular base is r
so the breadth will be h and the length
will be 2 pi r
don't forget
the area of this rectangle will be the
curved surface area
but we need to find the total surface
area of the cylinder
the surface area will be the sum of all
these three surfaces
two circles and the curved surface which
is the rectangle
the area of the circular base is pi r
squared
since there are two equal circles
we write pi r squared plus pi r squared
this covers the surface area of the top
and the bottom surfaces
and the area of this rectangle will be
length multiplied by breadth which will
be 2 pi r multiplied by h
this 2 pi r h is actually the curved
surface area of the cylinder
adding these like terms we get 2 pi r
square
and we write 2 pi r h as is
2 pi r is common to both the terms
so we write the final formula as 2 pi r
multiplied by r plus h
if we are given the radius of the base
and the height of the cylinder
using this formula
we can find out its total surface area
you